et puis enfin sachez que l'assemblée
nationale examine aujourd'hui la loi
sécurité globale dont toute une partie
consacrée à une réponse à l'émotion
suscitée par l'affairé halimi en juin
2010 est sara lee mines retraité de
confession juive et sauvagement tuée par
un de ses voisins et aucun procès la
cour de cassation a jugé l'auteur des
faits pénalement irresponsable a les
détails avec david kelly fin
plus ou moins soutenue à droite mais
pointé comme un énième texte sur la
sécurité intérieure par la gauche
commande faite en avril dernier par le
chef de l'état je le rappelle après la
vive émotion face à l'absence de procès
dans la sphère sarah halimi c'est aussi
ça qui est pointé du doigt l'opposition
estime que ce projet de loi est réalisée
sous le coup de l'émotion alors dans les
grands lignes que contient ce projet
doit le gouvernement maintient la règle
générale selon laquelle on ne juge pas
elle est fou mais ajoute deux exceptions
réprimer le fait pour une personne
d'avoir consommé des produits
psychoactifs en sachant que cela pouvait
à la conduire à des violences soit un
homicide l'ado est elle a été déclaré
irresponsable seconde exception lorsque
l'abolition du discernement résulte de
la consommation proche et volontaire de
psychotropes dans le but de commettre
une infraction un projet de loi qui est
censée répondre à la vague de
protestations et émergentes qui a fait
suite à la sphère sarah allait me mais
pour les associations il ne convient pas
car elle estime que l agresseur ou
meurtrier ne sera pas jugé sur le crime
qu'il a commis mais sur sa consommation
de stupéfiants
elle est victime de l'irresponsabilité
pénale
elle représente 400 personnes à peu près
par an 1 selon l association delphine
sandrine et ses victimes veulent tout
simplement un vrai procès reconnaissant
lac soit le même droit que pour toutes
les victimes beaucoup de questions en
suspens les députés auront fort à faire
lors de cette première lecture au sein
de l'hémicycle